the Joe Rogan experience Kurzweil is a
fascinating character yeah he thinks
he's gonna be around forever yeah I was
wrapping him up yeah
have you discussed any of this stuff
with him you know I don't know him
personally I have certainly gone to some
of his talks and I think he and I had
one exchange at some point in the past
and I totally get where he's coming from
you know he feels that we're perhaps the
final mortal generation and how sad it
is after you know a hundred thousand
generations of humans if we could only
stick around for one more generation
science would come to a point where we
would be immortal and that feels like a
tragic state of affairs I don't think
he's right and I think most people who
think about this deeply don't think he's
right either however many vitamins you
take and however much science is
progressing the notion that we are just
a generation or two from immortality I
think is wishful thinking this is a
strange concept of immortality to
because it's not necessarily you it's a
downloaded version of you that will
exist in some sort of computer right
which is what does that mean right that
sounds like hell yeah it could be yeah
you know hi I'm sleep in the computers
well I allow for the possibility that
that maybe it would be a way of being in
the world that would have upsides that
are hard for us as flesh-and-blood
individuals to appreciation or at this
point but it raises the deep question
would that be a good thing in fact if
you had that opportunity to be
downloaded in some form and that would
allow you to hold on to all your
memories build new memories on top of
them have experiences maybe there's an
avatar that you're able to drive but
through you know your mental
machinations is out there in the world
would you do it I might have said yes
before I've had some pretty profound
psychedelic experiences and then from
then I said I'm gonna hedge my bets let
me see what's next right let's see what
happens when the lights go out oh really
do you think there may be something to
have
when the lights go out I don't know yeah
I don't know what I mean for sure your
body is going to decay and you are going
to become a part of the earth you're
becoming part unless they cremate you or
unless they write embalm you with some
toxic chemicals and then nothing can use
your your dead tissue which is really a
shame yeah it's a really shame that we
do that right yeah I mean unless the
murders you and you have to exhume you
in the past assault in the future
whether to solve a murder
[Applause]